oh my god
in a normal tandem you don't have to
advise them of anything because it's an
experience right so
just have your experience if you're
scared feel your fear you know that's
kind of the point of this right you're
not going skydiving because it's like
you know
stamp collecting or playing chess right
you're doing something that's supposed
to be exciting
and it looks like she's having something
exciting what's up gq
i'm jeb corliss i'm a professional
skydiver and base jumper
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up mission impossible fallout
what i really love about this particular
shot is that this was all shot in like
one sequence so they want to show
that it's actually tom cruise who's the
one doing the jump and it's not a stunt
guy because that's like super important
for them
during this scene i remember my buddy
his name's craig o'brien he's the
cameraman who's actually
filming this scene so they specifically
built that helmet
with that like visor with an oxygen
system in it because they're actually
leaving from 25 000 feet so he needs air
and they put lights in it so you can see
that it's actually tom cruise
leaving the aircraft himself which is a
really big deal this was actually
incredibly difficult to film
because they're changing focal points i
mean that that this is impressive this
is no green screen this is this is all
done for real which
for me i think is it makes it more
special it makes it more interesting
altitude 25 000 feet
you need to have supplemental oxygen
inside of an aircraft when you're
skydiving
above 16 500 feet that's where they
start sticking stuff in their nose
and they're you you only need it inside
the aircraft at that point when you
start breathing
then they can take it out and jump out
of the aircraft at 25 000 feet
you need to have full oxygen system full
air the entire time or you will pass out
like you'll go unconscious
when you're gonna do a skydiving you're
gonna open up and it's gonna be
unpressurized
you have to have solid like breathing
the entire time and what they'll
normally do
is even beyond that just to make sure a
person's body is extra saturated with
oxygen
they'll put them on pure oxygen on the
ground
for like an hour to like two hours
before they go up to do the actual stunt
if they become hypoxic and you're doing
a skydive that can equal some very
dangerous situations
so tom cruise had to go through an
enormous amount of training
and do a lot of prep before getting to
this point it's one of the most
technically demanding scenes i've ever
seen an actor actually do
walker what's the matter huh afraid of a
little lightning
this whole scene is very real and this
is where they start adding in
kind of movie like hollywood stuff like
there's a cloud
and they're like you know a storm that
they're flying into and there's
lightning
like striking and stuff this is
obviously cgi but they're actually
really genuinely in
like a skydive at high altitude and then
they add all these components in
you don't jump through youth lightning
clouds
because the chances of like lightning
striking and damaging you and killing
you is high
so they create a realistic scenario
this whole scene of them him catching
him and him being unconscious and him
trying to like
you know work with him and wake him up
they did all this for real
they actually built a giant wind tunnel
on the studio lot and they spent hours
training this sequence in a wind tunnel
so they could do it in the sky for real
altitude
10 000
[Music]
and the timing between when they're
saying the altitudes
seems to be pretty accurate there
actually is an altimeter
that does call out your altitudes now it
tells you when you're at like you know
12 000 feet then i'll say 11 000 and
then as you get even lower
it starts counting it out even even more
even his visors fogged up
so if you don't have an oxygen flow
running the visor actually gets fogged
so it's actually the fact that they're
so detail-oriented that they've even
fogged his visor
i mean it's that's impressive let's keep
going
in real life the concept of switching
oxygen
um in the air would be physically
impossible because oxygen systems don't
work that way
they created an oxygen system to make
that concept work
in real life the auction bottles are
attached to you and it's that's a little
trickier to
accomplish but how they've set it up the
way they put the story together the way
they have their equipment designed
it's all possible based in the the
system that they've
structured
[Music]
deploy
[Music]
they're being so like critical with
their accuracy
the fact that they are actually having
tom cruise flip him over
before deploying him is actually really
interesting because yeah he could have
deployed him on his back but it's more
likely he'll get a malfunction
this ethan hunt character is so like you
know perfection
that he actually wants to flip him over
to give him the best chance of having a
good deployment
even when it's risking himself because
they're so low and the altitudes they're
showing
is looking very real it's looking like
that's right about where you would be
when they're saying the altitude that
they would be
at
[Music]
where he deploys at the very last second
parachute
inflates catches and puts in there
that's obviously done with cgi
but it's it's incorporated really well
and it's pretty accurate i've actually
had openings like that myself where i've
deployed and instantly hit like a tree
and hung
under normal circumstances for a
de-licensed skydiver right now they're
saying the altitude for
safe deployments is around three
thousand feet the reason why they say
three thousand feet is because that
gives you time
for if you have a malfunction to cut
away your malfunction get rid of the
parachute that's not working properly
and still have enough time to open a
reserve your secondary parachute
so in this scenario you could probably
go as low as
500 feet and i would say in this it's
looking like he probably would have been
deploying around
anywhere between 300 to 500 feet
give or take you know and and that's
with specialty base jumping gear you
could do that with skydiving gear
it's a little trickier so it took tom
cruise about 250 skydives of training
jumps
to get that shot and then over a
six-week period
they had a three-minute window one
jump every evening in order to get the
lighting at just the perfect kind of
light
to be able to do all that cg to put the
clouds in the city underneath them
so it took over six weeks of one jump a
night
at that three-minute little window in
order to capture that scene incredible
that's an impressive scene there's just
no question the filming the execution
i i wouldn't have any critique saying
how they could do it better that was
about as good as you can do
next up point break
i remember when i saw this scene the
first time actually watching an actor
step out of the aircraft themselves
where you know it's the actor and not a
stunt man
was like a super huge deal at this time
and you know everyone thought skydiving
was super crazy dangerous
so seeing patrick swayze actually do
that stunt
i remember it was like mind blowing it
really was
which i think that was the whole point
of him going out backwards was much more
about showing you that patrick swayze
was doing this for real
[Music]
this scene is where things start getting
very hollywood and very unrealistic
so the concept is more psychological he
doesn't have a parachute so if he
doesn't
catch him and get a grip on him he's
going to die
it's absolutely possible to catch up to
someone um
if the character as you can see the
patrick swayze character
is falling belly to earth and then they
show the keanu reeves character kind of
in almost a head down tracking position
he'll be going a lot faster than the guy
falling belly to earth
so it has to do with how much you weigh
and how much surface area you take up
so you can change speeds based on that
the time frame they're stretching this
out for obviously cinematic purposes
this would have to have happened much
faster than what they're showing here
a skydive typically lasts from 12
500 feet about 45 seconds
maybe 50 55 to 45 seconds depending on
what you're doing
and here you can actually see the stunt
man has a hidden rig
underneath his shirt so you can see that
he's got a special shirt that will break
off
open up so he actually has a parachute
underneath because obviously they didn't
do this for real
[Music]
so this is this is where it starts
getting really kind of hilarious because
they're yelling at each other and
talking in free fall which
without a full face helmet and aerial
communication if you have just your face
out and you're like yelling at someone
no one's gonna hear you you're doing
over 120 miles an hour
if you ever stick your head out of a
window of moving car like at 60 miles an
hour it's impossible to communicate like
this
pull the cord now now you pull it
go ahead johnny pull it you got to drop
the gun right
what a lot of people don't realize is
that when you've got two people
hanging on to each other um that
combined body weight in that
small surface area generates an enormous
amount of speed
so they'll start going so fast that even
if he was holding on with
all of his might and had his legs
wrapped around him if he deploys his
parachute he's just going to get ripped
out of his hands
it's pretty much physically impossible
to hold
on to someone in this scenario and i
kind of
know this from personal experience i
tried to do this with a buddy of mine
and we held on to each other and we got
to terminal velocity and when i went to
deploy
i mean he just got ripped from my arms
there was a zero percent chance i could
hold on to it a lot of people who see
this are gonna be like hey but people
have done this like people have jumped
out of aircraft
and grabbed onto other people and then
they've opened and and that has happened
i know of three different people travis
pastrana did it a guy named sean palmer
did it
but the way they do it is actually wear
a harness and then that harness they
have another
hook that hooks into the harness on the
skydiving rig that's the only way they
can actually take the force
of the deployment without it like
ripping their arms and their fingers off
[Music]
as long as you have an inflated canopy
over your head you'll hit and sometimes
you can hit kind of hard
but usually it'll be something like that
you're covered in dirt and if you
weren't injured before
there's a good chance you could walk
that off and the other guy who had a
previous injury can't
so that's within reason so
that scene is one of those classic
scenes that you know you see when you're
young and then you think
man could that really be done and the
answer to the question is
no that that's not realistic in even the
slightest sense but
i will say this it's very entertaining
to watch next up
san andreas in three minutes we're gonna
be over the embarcadero and
and we're going to drop into 18t park
but i don't know how to parachute it's
okay we're going to tandem jump
so tandem skydiving is when you have a
person who's got a large parachute with
a harness
and then the second person is going to
wear another harness that hooks into the
harness
that the person with the parachute has
so it's a way for someone who's a novice
who doesn't know how to skydive or have
any experience with skydiving
can then do a skydive with zero training
so
that's where this is interesting that
they've actually used this concept
to be able to take a novice out of an
aircraft and make it somewhat
plausible trust me
oh my god
i i find this kind of interesting
they're in an actual jump plane like
that's a door
that's specifically for skydiving like
that's a very special door
and the only aircraft i've ever seen in
the world that has a door like that
is a skydiving aircraft because it's
designed to be lifted up easily
it's designed so people can get out
freely without hitting things and having
obstructions
it's also interesting that this
particular aircraft just happened to
have
a tandem rig with a tandem harness in it
and not too many aircraft are built like
this and not too many aircraft would
ever
and even a skydiving aircraft wouldn't
have a tandem just in it
whoever the rock was like getting like
training from
did a really good job teaching him
because this is exactly how
a tandem instructor would be talking
would be operating would be doing
and as far as like get sitting out on
the edge and then pushing out that's
normally how a tandem will exit because
it makes it a little more comfortable
especially with a small door like this
one this is kind of a smaller door for a
skydiving aircraft
i haven't done a tandems since i was
very young like that's
29 years ago but because i fly wingsuits
i'm always with the tandems so i'm
watching tandems leave aircraft like
every day and it's fun to watch tandems
leave because of the reaction of the
people doing it for the first time
and yeah lots of times they're screaming
they're crying
they're begging to stop it's actually i
actually find
watching tandems to be one of the most
enjoyable experiences of my life because
it's just so much fun watching people be
terrified i don't know i'm a little
sadistic like that but i love watching
tandems they give me so much joy
in a normal tandem you don't have to
advise them of anything because it's an
experience right so
just have your experience if you're
scared feel your fear you know that's
kind of the point of this right you're
not going skydiving because it's like
you know
stamp collecting or playing chess right
you're doing something that's supposed
to be exciting
and it looks like she's having something
exciting
[Music]
you have to go through a very strict
like regiment
program to learn how to do this and most
tandem instructors have thousands of
jumps
it's something where you it takes a lot
of time a lot of dedication and most
people have to turn it into a career
in order to really do it
so this is quite interesting because
they're they're really doing this
exactly how a tandem would work so what
happens is they leave the aircraft
once they're clear they actually release
something called a drogue chute
which is a small round parachute that's
attached to the main
rig and it holds you stable so that you
don't fall too fast with two bodies
connected to each other
so it slows you down and it stabilizes
you so the fact that they're actually
using a drogue shows that they're pretty
much doing this for real
when he grabs her arms and pulls them
down that's them trying to tell
a story that they're trying to make
movement right that's
a track where they're trying to slide on
air to move closer to
the landing area that they're trying to
get to that would
be effective if a person's by themselves
it's not really super effective when
you're doing a tandem with two bodies
and a drogue chute kind of
keeping you stabilized
[Music]
i i think it's a pretty good scene
there's a few obvious little hollywood
things but other than that
the idea of using a tandem to get down
to some place when everything's
destroyed
that's a realistic concept if you had
all that equipment in that
exact scenario that they set up next up
furious
7. okay
here we go
that's okay they're launching a car out
of an aircraft
it's interesting because i can already
see like right off the bat something
that's bizarre which is the car came out
of the aircraft
and is now flying stable which is very
unrealistic with any kind of vehicle it
gets out of an aircraft if the vehicle
doesn't have a drogue chute like keeping
it stabilized
it'll instantly start tumbling
okay so yeah they're showing multiple
cars coming out
all coming out perfectly stable that's
very unrealistic there are times when
you would drop
humvees tanks cars whatever it is that
you would drop them from an aircraft
ordinarily you'd do it from lower
altitude you would have them launched
out on pallets
that have round parachutes attached to
them so as they come out the parachute
instantly opens which keeps everything
stable
and they drop them in big open areas so
that they can land wherever they land
then once it hits people come to them
get them off the pallet and drive them
away
so the fact there's no pallet and you
can't see a parachute of any kind
anywhere it's already incredibly
unrealistic
we gonna circle around and make sure we
holding it down from up here
you're running out of time the shoot is
guided by gps
that's really funny she's like the shoot
is guided by gps
i i've seen this obviously this movie
and i they have round parachutes around
parachutes you can't guide they just go
where the wind blows on this thing
shoots not a guy by gps but okay hey man
listen
i'm sorry to let y'all down okay i'ma go
ahead and stay up here
no brother i'm sorry to let you down
[Applause]
what
so i find that kind of interesting how
they have a little drogue shoot to like
pull him out
because that's what all of them should
have had from the very first to keep
them stabilized
but what's interesting is it pulls him
out and then as it gets out it instantly
releases
sending him into a tumble which it's
funny that his vehicle for some reason
isn't magical like the rest of theirs it
just flies perfectly somehow it's
tumbling but theirs weren't
it's kind of interesting because they're
showing that the ground's coming fast
they're all falling towards it i don't
understand why they didn't just open a
parachute right away i mean why are you
going and free fall in a car
it doesn't seem to make any sense but i
guess they're in a rush
but if they're in a rush why would you
lodge so high why not just launch close
to the ground
that doesn't make any sense
you would use a round parachute pretty
much for this situation
for dropping big payloads like big cars
when they're bringing like you know
parts of spaceships back to earth it's
always round parachutes right because
they're
they're very reliable and they can hold
lots of weight you can make them very
large so they're scalable
so you can drop tanks with them right
but the problem with the round parachute
is there's no control over around
parachute
and the fact that they're all in
formation this defies
physics it defies reality and and i
think that that's what i've seen with
the fast and furious movies they kind of
started out as like
realistic movies where it's kind of
based in the real world and then as the
numbers got higher
they're not even trying to be realistic
i find it funny and interesting but
if you're trying to say is it real can
this be done
not like this but honestly i don't think
the car would fall apart in the air
i think it would fall apart once it hit
the ground next up
point break this one i have a kind of a
close connection to because i actually
worked as technical advisor on this one
the director's concept was to make this
as
real as it could possibly be
right now these four wingsuit pilots are
exiting a cliff
called the young frau in la to burn in
switzerland it's actually two different
cliffs that this is filmed on
one for the actual exit where they jump
and then two for where they're actually
flying
and they're all doing this for real this
is all shot in camera
base jumping is an acronym for building
antenna span
and earth and when you incorporate
wingsuit flying which can also be done
skydiving
with base jumping it's called wingsuit
base jumping but this is taken to even
another level
which is something called wingsuit
proximity flying
so now not only are they base jumping
wingsuits
but they're then going to take those
wingsuits and fly very close to terrain
as a team so this is probably the apex
in what can be done in in the jumping
environment this
is hands down the most dangerous
wingsuit sequence that's ever been
filmed
in my personal opinion
wingsuit designs have been being
developed and built for a very long time
modern wing suits didn't start getting
developed with like ram air technology
and using modern day zero porosity like
nylon materials until the mid 90s so
since the mid 90s
up until now it's literally every year
developers are using wind tunnels and
and
thousands of jumpers around the world to
start like fine-tuning what a wingsuit
is capable of
so they keep getting better stronger
faster better glides
and and more flying characteristics each
year
a lot of these shots when you see them
they look like they're either on a green
screen or they're not real but they
are real they have a camera guy who's
actually flying with a camera facing
backwards
and they would actually face this camera
in all these different directions in
order to capture
all of these different angles that you
don't normally get to see
so the only things in here that you'll
see that are cgi
is they'll sometimes put a little cloud
or maybe a like a tree will go between
camera and pilot
that's all originally it was slated to
have six jumps to capture all the angles
they needed
all of a sudden about three weeks into
filming i was asking
one of the jumpers like you know hey how
many jumps have you guys done i've kind
of lost count and like oh we've done
about 60 so far
and i'm like you've done 60 jumps
i couldn't believe it was that many
jumps that it was taking to capture
all the angles they needed so that gives
you an idea of how complicated that
scene was to film
this is without a doubt the closest any
human being has ever flown to the ground
for the longest period of time
without making contact and without dying
this shot has always blown me away it's
and in my opinion it is the craziest
shot
i've ever seen put on camera because
these men are moving at over 120
miles per hour in a very tight space
without the ability to stop
how long you can stay in flight in a
wing suit depends on how high of
altitude you're jumping from
so this particular cliff is about 5 000
feet tall it's basically a mile high
and this flight particular flight you
can fly for around
two and a half minutes and if you count
your canopy time it can be up to three
minutes
so this is actually a pretty realistic
representation of how long the flight
would be
it depends on what you're doing but i
always wear a helmet
i used to wear a helmet with goggles now
i wear a helmet with a visor
because i like to keep the air off my
face and out of my eyes because we have
a tendency to go so incredibly fast
if you were to actually impact the
ground at those speeds
the helmet really probably won't help
you very much now
you also have to have a helmet for when
you're coming in for landing under
parachute
so you could have a landing where you
kind of fall down and hit your head and
then the helmet will be useful for that
people ask like you know how do you turn
a wingsuit how do you control a wingsuit
and i'm always like well how do you
walk right how do you explain walking to
someone right it becomes
second nature what it takes to become a
wingsuit pilot you do all the thousands
of skydives and
you go through the training with the
wingsuit by the time you get to the
level that you can control one properly
you just think it and you do it just
like you're a dancer dancing right you
tell your body and it just kind of does
it until you get that kind of muscle
memory and your body becoming used to it
it's actually quite challenging over
time with practice with training like
anything in your life
you know you will get to a place where
it becomes automatic for you
one of the main differences between
skydiving and base jumping
is in skydiving you've got two
parachutes in base jumping
because we're jumping from so low we're
deploying
even lower there's no time to cut away
and open a reserve so on most base jumps
you are actually using a single
parachute system
so that means if your main parachute
doesn't work it's over
and that's one of the reasons why the
sport is so dangerous and why this scene
was so dangerous but having said that
when you've only got one shot you take
that shot very seriously so the
equipment is much
simpler it's much it's less likely to
have malfunctions
and you treat it like you pack it like a
reserve every time so
it's literally perfection for every jump
you have something called a pilot chute
and that pilot chute sits
underneath your container in something
called a boc which means
bottom of container and and that pilot
chute is attached to a bridle
a piece of webbing that goes up to pins
that keep the container closed so as a
wing suit pilots flying
when they decide to deploy they fold
their wings
reach back grab that little pilot chute
in the boc
they yank it out and throw it into the
wind and as it catches air it's a little
tiny round parachute
that creates drag that then pulls the
bridle
pulls the pins and then pulls the main
canopy out so
it's basically the same process that we
use on skydiving as well
it's just a little more advanced because
you have to get around a wing
that's it if you're doing a really
dangerous jump that you know
can potentially cause serious damage
what goes to your mind is very different
than if you're doing a jump that's very
safe
by comparison wingsuit flying i've
noticed is really scary
as you're exiting but once you exit the
sensation is that you have control and
you
feel almost it's impossible to describe
it it is that dream you had as a child
you feel like you're flying you feel
like you have control
and it's very powerful it's something
that will draw you
in over and over i i love it it's a very
wonderful sensation
the filming of this scene even after all
these years seeing it
it still hasn't been topped like this is
still the greatest wingsuit flying
sequence i've ever seen filmed
next up iron man 3.
the reality is if you were to get sucked
out of an aircraft
at that altitude you'd pass out almost
instantly because you have no oxygen
so the first problem with that is the
altitude that a commercial jetliner
flies let's just say 30 000 feet for the
sake of argument
and then a normal skydiving plane
without oxygen is around 12
000 feet so there's you know there's
quite a discrepancy there
see that guy i'm gonna swing by are you
just gonna grab him
you got
i'll it your arm you won't be able to
open your hand
i mean marvel you know obviously this is
a comic book movie it's not even meant
to be even remotely real
but this idea of him putting electricity
through her hands so it like
seizes up so she won't let go well
that's a great idea
but i'm sorry a person's body weight
will rip her fingers off so
it's not realistic but you know hey
they're trying to explain it a person's
weight doesn't change while falling
but their weight based on their surface
area will change the speed
at which they're falling so let's just
say you weigh
200 pounds and you have the surface area
of a six foot four
man spread out as wide as they can do
catching as much air as possible
you can probably slow that person down
to
maybe if they're wearing baggy clothes
like a hundred miles an hour
whereas if they get into like a tracking
position where their arms and legs are
together and their head down
you can get it to be over 200 miles an
hour i think the record is close to 300.
so that's how this works actually most
of those people are my really good
friends and i remember when they were
filming this they were always calling it
barrel of monkeys
but this is an actual real technical
filming in the sky of people falling
at least that part's real remember that
game called barrel
of monkeys that's what we're gonna do 18
000 feet
come on people everybody grab your
monkey
it's beautifully shot like the the them
incorporating
actual real footage of people in free
fall and the cgi of iron man and
them grabbing each other it's really
well done it stitched together in a way
that
suspension of disbelief is actually easy
to have here formation skydiving is a
massive thing
and they actually break world records i
think the world record right now
i think it might be 400 people flying
all at the same time
all connected in formation so yes it's a
thing that's very big
a lot of people focus their entire
skydiving careers on just formation
skydiving
[Music]
if you're landing in water from a
skydive with a parachute it's actually
quite nice you know it's not a problem
you land nice and soft
you have to be careful like when some
people like want to cut their canopies
away when they hit
because you can get pulled under by it
in current so you just have to be
careful that you're touching water
when you cut away because the depth
perception of water when
chopping a parachute sometimes people if
they're not touching the water they'll
think they're closer than they are and
they'll cut away too high
and then they'll get really badly hurt
what a lot of people don't realize is
that water is as hard as concrete
if you hit it at a high enough speed so
you'd have to slow someone down
to a speed probably in like the 30 40
maybe 50 mile per hour range in order
for them to hit
like gently enough to survive
next up last holiday so are you ready
yes i am go get a man
damn camera going we're rolling go ahead
okay
it's funny because you know they're
about to jump off of a dam
in wing suits which is absolutely
unrealistic i mean that this thing can't
be more than like
600 feet tall which is too low for
flying wing suits for sure
they don't have dams that are high
enough you want to have at least
minimum like a thousand feet to launch a
wingsuit to get enough airspeed to move
you far enough away to deploy a
parachute safely
i have told you before we have lost a
couple of
people doing this well like people died
yeah so the
the the fact that she's like surprised
that people have died doing this is
really quite funny
they're going on the assumption she's
never done a skydive never done a base
jump
and now she's doing a wingsuit base jump
which is
so outside any realm whatsoever and if
she were to do this
she would 100 die this is something
where you need
to be trained like highly skilled
trained to do this
so this is absolutely outsold the realm
of any kind of reality
whatsoever if a person wanted to get to
the level of
base jumping a wingsuit and they were
starting from zero meaning no skydives
you're looking at spending at least
between five and ten years of dedicating
your life to it hundreds if not
thousands of skydives
and then hundreds if not thousands of
base jumps to be able to accomplish what
she's about to do
all right three two one
go
[Music]
what's really funny is that when they
were doing the stunt obviously the
stuntman knew
that this was absolutely unrealistic or
unreasonable to do the jump in a
wingsuit so the wings are actually you
can see them cut off so when he puts his
arms up the wings aren't actually
attached
so he's actually doing a bass jump like
a regular bass jump with what looks like
kind of a wingsuit but it's not really a
wingsuit
so they actually did a practical jump
obviously but not with a real wingsuit
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
okay i don't know why they put the
wingsuit on i think it was just kind of
trying to show like
that must have been like a really like
trendy thing at the time because they
just did a regular bass jump she didn't
actually fly or they didn't try to make
it look like she was flying they made
her just do a bass drum so there was
literally zero reason to even have a
wingsuit on in the first place
so i don't know that's just
confusing i'm confused let's let's get
caught up it's their problem
uh yeah i tell ya there's a problem in
my class i know i think or two about
base jumping i know that the canopy is
supposed to be connected to the reiki
and it's not and that's how people get
killed no wonder you've lost a few
people
so that's kind of funny because they're
kind of showing that he's making up some
reason for why his equipment is not
proper so he can chicken out
which that's the only realistic thing in
this whole scene anyone with a brain
wouldn't be doing that
period like you would never do that
but the stupid excuse that he's making
up they obviously talk to real base
jumpers because that would be
if your canopy wasn't attached to your
rig you wouldn't jump because yeah you
would die
so that's true but honestly if he had
jumped even with the grig
he'd still die there's no living in that
scenario with someone who has no
experience
next up deadpool 2. i hate to interrupt
but
is anybody nervous about the high winds
gary my name's peter i realize that
you're new to this
i spent 10 years at special forces you
think we didn't jump out of the plane
because of a light
breeze if you jump in really terrible
wind like how they're setting up this
scene
it's gonna go bad for you it's it's not
gonna end well
and if you have real if you have wind as
strong as what they're suggesting
then actually what's about to happen is
probably pretty realistic because
you have no control under canopy and if
you have no control under canopy
when you're coming into a city or urban
environment
with like let's just say 40 or 50 mile
an hour winds
well then it's going everyone's going to
get destroyed like it's going to cause
serious problems
[Music]
the kind of normal guy with the mustache
is just like
he's doing exactly what a person does
when they're super terrified in their
first skydive
they kind of like get in they like sit
down like that's going to somehow help
them they're getting closer to the
ground before they go
it's actually really funny
[Music]
obviously this is all fake none of this
is real it's all done green screen and
cgi but this is probably one of the
better
done cgi skydiving scenes i've seen
partially because it's just hilarious
but then because of the actual motions
like as you see the cameras coming in
and the movements
they made it pretty real for being fake
skydiving has all kinds of different
positions for flying
there's two different disciplines that
like primarily focus on that
one is called freestyle and that's where
you do all these special tricks it looks
almost like dancing in the sky
and then the other one more common and
more frequently done these days is
something called
free flying and free flying has i mean
it's unlimited the limits of where you
can position your body and how you can
fly your body is pretty much to your
imagination
um they're not doing any of that in this
scene no one's doing any free flying
it's all pretty much tracking right now
they're just doing like this really
specific tracking
[Music]
[Music]
but what's great about that scene is
that he looks up and he just sees
everyone's canopy is like tumbling in
the sky
i've actually watched people open in
winds that were so strong
that it actually puts them sideways and
it's flying them backwards i mean
if you jump in strong enough wind that
kind of stuff can happen and
what that's showing is that they're all
an absolutely horrifying wind that's
unacceptable they shouldn't have jumped
and that's the idea of this scene i
guess
there are square parachutes elliptical
parachutes and round parachutes
so round parachutes have very limited um
forward motion meaning they don't have
much control
a square parachute has much more control
in how you can fly
and and give you range and distance to
land where you need to land
elliptical parachutes are even faster
and have even more range and can give
you more distance
so the different shapes of parachutes
dictate what type of
landing you're trying to have you want
to have a high speed
like fast landing you use elliptical if
you want to have like a very
precision landing then you use a square
parachute if you want to have just a
round parachute that's just
you have a big open landing area without
anything to hit well then a round
parachute will get you on the ground
with very little input
hitting power lines is probably the
single most
um threatening thing you can have if you
hit power lines with a parachute
the possibility of you being
electrocuted to death are very high and
unfortunately it has happened in the
past but also what will happen sometimes
is you'll hit the power line and because
you're not grounded you'll still be okay
and if that's the case if you were to
land in power lines and it doesn't
actually fry you
and you're hanging you have to be really
careful because if someone
touches you then they can become they
can ground you and then the power can
come through the power line through you
and through them and kill both of you
so yes that is a thing and yes you
don't ever want to do that you want to
avoid that by all costs at all costs
most skydiving is done at um designated
drop zones like places that are
designated for skydiving it's very very
rare
for skydivers to land anywhere near a
city
base jumpers have a tendency to land in
cities more often because they have a
tendency to jump off
buildings and it's usually very highly
skilled
professional like highly professional
jumpers who are precision that do that
kind of stuff
next up along came paulie i'm just gonna
do a bit of a base jump
here keep the walker on channel 13 all
right
i don't know what you're talking about a
base jump a free-fall from an inanimate
object always carrying me shoot in case
i find a good launching point
it's actually kind of funny because in
the background he's like doing these
stretches
yeah i i don't usually do any sort of
sort of warm-ups when i'm getting ready
to do a base jump of this nature
i go to the position and then i just
jump off there's some psychological
stuff i'll sometimes do depending on how
scary the jump is
but in general you usually don't have
time
on jumps like this if you're in a city
and you're doing something that's
questionably the gray area legal like
you're
then you don't have time for that you
get up you go and you just get you get
off as quick as possible and you can see
that there's no parachute inside his
container
it's literally a container with no
parachute in like it's a a person who
doesn't like jump wouldn't notice that
but he has no parachute in there i got
your message oh
let's just start over and forget about
that
no oh holy [ __ ]
i didn't like that luffa i've always
really loved this scene i think it's
it's it's fun it's really a funny one
and my friend tim
is the one who actually does this stunt
and they did it in the middle of
downtown los angeles
i mean with permits and permission and
shutting down roads is incredible i mean
it's done for real so it's pretty cool
the story line of along came paulie was
supposed to be happening in new york but
the actual
stunt was done in los angeles and i
believe the reason
why is because new york is very strict
about
people jumping off of buildings even for
movies um
they just don't give permission for that
kind of stuff unfortunately
la's actually quite open to giving
permits and permissions
to filmmakers to actually shoot stunts
like this people are jumping off
skyscrapers every single day in every
city in the world
period people don't realize that but if
you look at a building that's high
enough to jump off it's being jumped off
it's just happening on this planet in
every country in every city
everywhere but base jumpers are usually
very quiet they're super secretive they
do it in the dark and you very rarely
see it
i have jumped off hundreds of
skyscrapers
in probably 20 different countries i
mean i jumped off the eiffel tower i did
a double reverse flip through the center
of the eiffel tower so that gives you a
little idea
[Music]
oh crap
obviously the story line is that he
pulls so low that he doesn't even have
time to like control and he ends up
hitting a tree
in real life they actually landed on the
road and then they put
my buddy inside of a harness and then
they drop him in a tree in order to make
it look like he's gone into the tree
tree landings are are random you never
really know what you can get so when you
land in a tree
it can either be the softest most gentle
nice landing you've ever had
or you can break branches that skewer
you and you can bleed to death before
anyone gets to you so
the the goal is to avoid landing in
trees because it's just
kind of random what can happen now in my
career i have
probably 10 tree landings and that's not
a good thing that's a bad thing but i've
had like 10g landings
and so far all of them have been pretty
gentle i mean they haven't been
so bad but i've had a few friends who it
didn't go so well for
so if you can avoid landing in trees
you do peppa you're there mate
yes before to leland hello come on down
and give us a hand
i think i might have fractured me coccyx
base jumpers usually will do that like
they'll give a walkie-talkie to someone
else
so that if anything goes wrong they can
communicate with them quickly to let
them know
something has gone wrong so that's
actually kind of a funny little like
thing that he does to make it a little
more
i guess real it's actually smart but
what's funny is him like on the walk
like saying hey come down i might have
broken my coccyx
i've actually landed in trees and called
people and said hey i needed some help
i'm kind of
i think i think i think i might have
broken something so it's actually funny
because that actually
has happened to me next up
[Music]
goldeneye
this is actually a really iconic scene
it's something that you know anyone
who's watched this movie this is
something that you will always remember
this is actually done practically they
actually have a plane go over the edge
and they have a man he was actually a
french base jumper and at the time
he was the the most advanced base jumper
on the planet i think he was the first
base jumper to reach a thousand jumps of
anyone in the world
and at the time he's the one they hired
to actually ride
the motorcycle off i think it was a
cliff called the hammer so this part of
the stunt where he's riding the
motorcycle off the edge of the cliff
is actually shot for real
now this you can tell is obviously fake
you can see the background and him in
this weird kind of body position
which is odd and you can see that this
is like some kind of
i don't even know what they're using but
it's like really bad green screen
[Music]
even though i can tell that this isn't
being done for real
in this film like this thing people have
done this for real just not from a
motorcycle like going off of a cliff
they've done
where one airplane goes drops and then
someone jumps out of another airplane
and then gets into that airplane that's
actually been done quite a few times
and it's probably where this stunt got
inspired
[Music]
when you do it for real when when they
make one airplane drop and another
person gets out and gets into that
airplane
they'll usually put a drogue chute on
the back of the plane so they have a
cable
with a little tiny parachute that will
make the airplane
fall at the same speed as the actual
skydiver does
so there's certain things you have to do
to the aircraft to prepare it
to be able for that to happen but
recently
there were two frenchmen they jumped off
of a cliff and had an airplane fly and
they were able to fly with the airplane
and get into it without a drogue chute
without anything
so it can be done with a wingsuit so
with a wingsuit you can actually get out
and get into an aircraft that's flying
without drogging it
without a wingsuit you'll have to drug
the aircraft in order to fly at the same
[Music]
speed
i mean it's classic james bond you know
doing like these big like tent pole
stunts that
you know in this one i liked because it
incorporated real
like the guy really riding a motorcycle
off the cliff going into a real bass
jump
as the plane is actually falling and
having it all in the same shot
really well done the flying next to the
airplane they obviously had to do that
with cgi and it was you know
obviously fake you could tell it wasn't
real but
i will say that that could be done in in
real life
um in different parts in different
pieces thank you so much for watching
these clips with me
i hope you enjoyed yourself i'll see you
next time